サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダタナン エタングブッダナササナん
では よろしくお願いします
今日は皆様いろいろ忙しいところなのに
調子とらない講義を今日聞いてもらいます
本当に感謝いたします
まあそう言うてすぐ頭がぼーっとしてきたからね
今日は布団に直した方がいいんじゃないかな
[笑い] と思ったりもしますが
では あの ちょっとスライドの枚数がちょっと多めになってしまったので
早速テーマに入ります
まああの 日本語のタイトルは考えられなくてね
Your personal advisor
英語のタイトルにしたんですね
まあ顧問というですね
個人の 失敗は人の個人指導者
いわゆる個人指導者っていう意味の顧問です
顧問ということは当然思い出しましたからね
このスライド このスライドを使うときは思い出さなかったんです
ということで この失敗っていうのは
私たちに何かアドバイスしてくれる個人的な顧問です
ですから とてもその面で見ればとてもありがたいことなんですね
それでも 一体失敗って何ですかね
これなんか変ですね まあ失敗っていうのは
自分が何かやる 何かやる場合は
必ず何か結果を期待しているんですね
必ず 例えば 私は今手を挙げて
こうやってちょっと鼻の後ろをかいだんですね
だから手を挙げたときは
何か目的 結果期待していたんですね
だから これは無意識的であろうが
意識的であろうが 何か行為をするときに結果を期待する
結果がそれではなかったならば
別の結果になった なってしまったら
これは失敗です それから面白いことは
行為に必ず結果がある
いかなる行為にも結果がある
その結果が期待したものか
期待しなかったものか
予測したものか予測しなかったものかということで
失敗か成功かと決めてしまう
それだけのことです 非常にシンプルですね
例えば 私はこのペットボトルからこのガラスに水を入れようとする
で 期待する結果は ガラスの中に丁寧に水が入ることですね
それでガラスの中ではなくて
中にも入るんだけど 外にも水が流れていくと
私たちは失敗と 水がこぼれてしまいましたと
というんです そういうことです
そうすると成功した方がいいですね
ガラスに綺麗に水をこぼれないように入れて入れることができたら
これは成功です いいことですね
それは 我々はいつでもそういうことを期待する
成功することを期待する
誰も失敗したいと思わないんですね
成功したいです お茶飲む時も
お茶が口に入らないでこぼれちゃって
服を濡れることを期待しないんです
ちょっと何かで手が揺れちゃって
今日の朝みたいに地震でも起きちゃって
ちょこっとカップが揺れてしまってこぼれたらそれが失敗なんですね
だから失敗は我々は期待しない
失敗すると誰も思わない
成功したいと思っている
そこまではわかっている
次もう一つあります 失敗のこと
カエルさんがじーっと草の中に隠れて待っている
何か昆虫でも来ないのかと
そこでグラスホッパーという昆虫がいるんですね
草の上にいる緑の虫が
なんて言いますかね 日本語で
え？イナゴは緑はない
緑色じゃないね え？バッタ
バッタが待ってるんですね
バッタが葉っぱ食べたいんですね
そこでまあ葉っぱじゃなくて
隣の葉っぱの方が美味しいんじゃないと判断して飛ぶ
ちゃんと飛べたらバッタさんが成功しましたね
待ってるカエルさんがペロッとベロを出す
そこでどうなるのかと
ベロを出したところにバッタを取られたらカエルさんが成功です
バッタは大失敗です 命がなくなったんです
もしカエルさんがベロを出しても
バッタはもう飛んでるんですね
そうするとカエルさんが失敗したんです
バッタは成功したんです
それで我々は何かわかりますかね？何かわかりますかね
じゃあ バッタとカエルさんの方でどちらが成功した方がいいんですかね
わかりやすく言えば 両方とも成功した方がありがたいでしょ
でもそれはなりたたないね
どちらか成功するとどちらか失敗する
それも覚えておいてください
この成功ばっかりじゃ
失敗は絶対したくないというね
いい加減ではなくて なんか変ですね
このこと二つは  観念的に言えば
誰だって成功した方がよろしいんです
これは慈しみの気持ちでもありますね
慈悲喜捨の喜 喜びの気持ち
だって成功すると喜びですからね
だから生きとし生けるものが
願い事が叶えられますようにと我々は念じますよ
でもなんか ちょっと問題ですね
カエルさんの願い事を叶え叶えたら
バッタの願い事はまるっきり叶わなかったんです
命がなくなっちゃったんです
バッタの願い事が叶ったならば
カエルさんが食べ物がなくなっちゃったというんですね
それはこういうバッタとカエルさんだけではなくて
全ての生命にあることなんです
我々にもあります 一人が成功すると一人が失敗するということは
人間の社会にもあります
なので世の中でね 今は自由経済ですからね
まあ資本主義とも言いますけど
私はこの資本主義という言葉はあまり好きじゃないんです
ちょっと好きじゃないんです
キャピタリズムというのも
別に感情ではなくて それなりの深い意味があるんです
自由経済という言葉はね
フリーエコノミー 私は仏教的に好きな言葉なんですね
人間がそれぞれ頑張って
自分の能力に適した収入を得る
そこは自由にしてあげてあげて
誰でも頑張ってください
自分の能力に適した収入を得て生活してくださいというのは
仏教的には経済観念ですね
資本主義というのは恐ろしいんですね
資本ある人が豊かになって
資本がない人が知ったことじゃないと
それは良くないんです
だから私たちはやっぱり自由経済を応援するべきであって
資本主義を別に応援する必要はないんです
資本主義も共産党が教えているあの経済も
あんなのはすごい残酷ですね
慈しみが入ってないんです
共産主義の国々の人間がすごく貧乏なんですね
国には金があるんです
残酷です 資本主義世界では一部は豊かで
一部はものすごい貧困で
病気になったら治療を受けることもできない状態で
それも残酷です はい そういうことで
まあ今の自由経済あるいは資本主義の世界の中を見ると
豊かな人がいて 生活は大変でなかなかうまくいかない人々もいる
ということは 一部が成功する
その結果 一部が失敗する
会社の面接で4人を雇いますということで
でも100人 それに合格する
希望するんですね それで100人も面接したら
96人が失敗する で 4
人が成功する そういうことはありますね
では 考えてみれば あの 96人では仕事をする資格がないんですかね？仕事しなくてもいいんですかね？違うでしょう
そういう若者の 96人もちゃんと就職して幸せで生きていきたいんです
なのに この世界では 人間の世界ででも
一人が成功すると一人が失敗する
一人の成功は一人の人の失敗になるということがあり得ます
ですから カエルさんとバッタのたとえをよく覚えてください
ということは 我々は成功ばっかり狙っている
生きることがよくないんです
たまに失敗してもいいんじゃないかと思いますよ
私は自分のことをいつも思い出しますけど
遠い昔 大学で仕事をしていた時はね
性格の悪い仲間がいたんですね
どうしようも わがままで人のことは心配しない
仕事もしない 給料だけもらって帰る
大学にもほとんど来ない
給料の日 たまたま 1ヶ月に 1回 2
回ぐらい来る感じで 私はその人の仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
人が来るか来ないかね
まあ我々アカデミックスタッフという教育関係だから
仕事があるんだよね それでこの人がこの留学したいということで
政府のいろいろ あの   1年にいろんな国々に留学に出す奨学金制度があるんだから
それに願書を出すんですね
それで大学の方が私にもあんまり出しなさいよと
このままではもうダメですから
なんとか留学してこなきゃ
もう仕事困りますよ ただ言われるんだから出そうじゃないかなと思ったら
同じ分野だからね あの人は一生懸命あちらこちら出してるんです
しかし この日本に来る日本の奨学金ですね
それその人が出したいと思っていて
年齢制限があるんです
その人にはあと 1ヶ月間しかないんです
そこですごく嫌々な顔をして
もう出さなくちゃ もう私
日本にはいっぱい友達も知り合いもいるんだから
日本に来て勉強するつもりではなかったんです
とにかく それで私は考えたんですね
私の先生たちがね 出しなさい
出しなさい あんたはすぐ受かりますって言うの
一応私にはかなり資格がありまして
もうスリランカの同じ年のグループの中で
私は大体点数的にはトップでしたからね
出すことはもう決まっているんです
私は考えたのは この一緒にいる
この人がも出して 私も同じ奨学金出して
私はいくらなんでも合格する可能性があまり高い
あと この人は一生恨んでいるだろうと
私は性格悪いな ですから
まあ私は出しません とはっきり宣言出さなかったんです
先生たちには怒られたんだけど
何するのか 先生にその理由は言わなかったんだけど
出しませんと言ったところで
何かすぐ落ち着いて ちゃんと願書を出して見事に拡大しました
見事にっていうのはおかしいんだけど
私学校ないんですよ やっぱり
それでそれから彼にはもう年齢超えちゃったんだから
次の年はできないんです
で 私は何のこともなく
じゃあ出してみようかなっていう感じで出しまして
まあ一応合格して日本に来るひどい運命になりました
来ていたらどうせいいことなかったんだけど
うん だから 私はまあやっぱり
一回失敗してもいいんじゃないかな
人をひどく悩ませる 一生人がね
恨みで悩ませるよりは
まあ一回一回負けてもいいんじゃないかなと思って
そういうふうに私なら意図的に負けることっていうのは結構あります
意図的に失敗する 相手のことを考えて
なぜならば 一人が成功すると一人が失敗すると
だからこの というか 法則を知らない人は失敗したら恨んでも
人のことを憎しんでも鬼になっちゃうんですね
悲しそうでしょ ですから
そういうのはまあということで
いつでもそういうわけじゃないんだけど嘛
たまに失敗してもいいこともあります
それだけなんです 人のために
だから必ず何でもかんでも成功しなくちゃいかんということは思なくちゃねえんです
子供と何かゲームやっていると
負けた方が楽しいでしょ
勝つよりは 私はだいたい子供を相手にしてゲームをやると
だいたい負けます で その方が勝ったよりは楽しいんです
逆に考えれば 自分で意図的に失敗することは失敗じゃないんですよ
だって自分はその結果期待していたんだから
すると期待した結果が起きるんだから成功なんです
はい そういうことも理解していましょう
じゃあまあ簡単な話はそれだけです
それからちょっとこの
難しい仏教の理論の話に行きます
お釈迦様は人類のこの上ない指導者です
皆さんは覚えている言葉ですね
サッハーデウマルスターナというのはお釈迦様の一つの稽古なんですね
神々と人間の師匠っていう意味なんですね
釈迦様は全ての生命の師匠です
釈迦様は真理を明かして実践方法を説きます
しかし 実践する個人に個人指導者が必要です
そこで釈迦様は偉大なる師匠ですから
こういうことであると
あなたはこういうふうにしてくださいっていうだけです
だから個人の弟子が自分で実践しなくちゃいけない
実践していると 誰かが一緒に付きっきりになって
これどうですか？どうですか？調べで師匠が一緒必要になるんですね
個人指導者が  先生 個人指導ですか？指導者ですね
今の文章なんです 個人指導ですか？個人指導者ですか
個人指導が必要です まあシャって付くのはどうでもいいんですけど
当然出家に師匠アサリなどがいる
我々出家したら 我々の師匠はお釈迦様ですけど
お釈迦様はいないんだから
経典を学んだり 戒律の法を学んだり
いろいろ勉強したりする
それはお釈迦様の教えですね
しかし 私たちには師匠がいるんです
師匠にくってもうさんざん怒られて怒鳴られているわけなんです
ほとんどもうね もう 24時間怒られっぱなしで
何やってるのかとかね
勉強じゃないだろうとかね
あれやこれや この歩き方間違ってるよと言われることも
もう法要なんかに行ってご飯食べてる時でも
なんでそんな食べ方は？とかね
みんなの前で言われるんで
なんで手を振ってるんですか？なんで足を振ってるんですか？情けないとかね
そういう風に さすがそんなこと言わないでしょうに
だから我々の師匠がずっと心配して
一つ一つ一つ一つ丁寧に教えちゃうんです
それでやっと一人前の出家とって成長するんです
最近にも説法し 瞑想指導者がいるんですね
最近 仏教に取り立っても
仏教を教えてくれる人が
お坊さんたちがいるし
また瞑想を教えてくれる人がいるし
そういうのは個人的に指導するということになるんですね
その理由は 先生が優秀だけでは
生徒が学問に成功するという保証はありません
お釈迦様みたいな偉大なる師匠がいても
あるいは出家に師匠みたいな個人指導者がいても
皆様にも瞑想を教えてくれる個人指導者がいても
成功する保証はないのです
そこがポイントなんです
あと 例えで書いたのは
ものすごく優秀な先生がいる
その先生のクラスに入ったら
抜群  100点満点で生徒たち成功する
そんな保証はないんです
なんかもう一つ欠けているんですね
生徒も素直に学ぶ必要があります
生徒にも仕事はあるんです
素直に学びなさいと 言うとおり
個人指導者とは 心の中にいて自分を戒める性格のことです
ですから 私はタイトルでパーソナルアドバイザーと書いたのは顧問ですね
これは学生さんの心の中にいるんです
これは学生さんが 私は優秀な先生のクラスに入りましたし
ですから私も真面目に勉強しなくちゃいけないと一人で勉強するんですね
そこで その学生さんが
その子供が これがよくわからない
これがまずい 今勉強する気持ちはないとかね
今勉強じゃなくて遊びたい気持ちがあるとか
いろいろ心の中に葛藤あるんですよ
それと戦って勉強しなくちゃいかないんですね
その心の中にある状況
真面目に学びたいという心の中にある気持ちが顧問です
それがなければ誰も成功しません
はい さらに仏教の理論に入ります
すべては不完全 心も体も物質と全世界も不完全です
不安定です この世の中で
この存在の中で何一つも安定していないんです
不完全 安定していないとは不完全ということなんです
これは諸行無常 いわゆるサッベーサンカーアニッチャーという言葉になります
諸行無常ということは皆様聞いてんですね
パーリ語でサッベーサンカーアニッチャー
すべてのものことは無常です
いわゆる変化します 変わります
なんで変わるんですか？不完全だから
今の状態は不安定なので
安定を目指して変わります
しかし 変わってみたらそれも不安定です
だからこれに終わりがないんです
したがって すべての現象は限りなく変化するんです
わかりやすく地球はエネルギーが不安定なんです
だから安定しようと思って自転するんです
自転してもしても不安定です
だからずっと地球は自転する
しかし 自転しただけでもさらに不安定なので公転もします
ということは このエネルギーのアンバランス状態が直らないんです
それで地球の自転公転は何なのかというと
地球が安定したいっていう気持ちで
その気持ちはないんですけど
物質ですからね 安定したいんです
このペットボトルで水が入ってますけど
この水は安定していないんです
変えようと思っているんです
しかし このペットボトルで邪魔されてそのままいるだけ
ちょっと穴を開けてみましょうか
どうなるのかな さっさと安定目指して水がこぼれていくんです
我々はそこを期待していないんだから
こぼれるという単語を使いますけど
水の場合は自分が正しい態度を取っています
安定を目指していくのです
しかし 永久的にこの水には安定状態はないんです
このままでも不安定状態
穴を開けたらこぼれたっても不安定な状態です
私がこれ飲んでも不安定な状態
変化する 変化する 変化する
変化する 終わりがない
だから変化する 無常 不安定
不完全っていうのは同じ現象
いろいろ立場から説明しているだけなんです
不安定な心 物質だけではなくて
物質はどうでもいいんで
別に問題ないんです 心
不安定なんです 心の不安定
無常はものすごい激しいんです
常に揺れ動くのです 心はもう物質よりものすごい速く変化するんです
ということは 心の不安定は並みじゃないんです
心も安定を目指して変化します
私たちはこのストレスというのは不安定ですね
悩みというのは不安定なんです
心困っているということは
心が困っている 体が困っているわけじゃないんです
腰が痛くて困っていると言っても
心が困っている 腰に痛みがないんです
ただの物体ですからね
心があるんだから痛みなんです
痛みは心なんです だから心の管理できる人には腰が痛いんだったら
そちらから心を離してもらっちゃえば
痛みはなくなっちゃうんです
心 そちらに行かない 時々体に問題ないのにすごい痛みがある場合がありますね
それでお医者さんが調べて調べて
もうどうしようもない異常なし
でも激痛 その場合 アメリカなんかは特別にこの
ペイントリートメントという瞑想とか
ヴィパッサナーの方法とか使っているんです
まあお医者さんたちですけど
まあこれは心の問題ですと
で 心の直す方法は他の宗教ではどこにもないんだから宗教ですから
それでお釈迦様が教えていただいた方法を見つけて
それはすごい科学でしょうし
このやり方を使っちゃえば
なんとか激痛を直せるんじゃないかなというやり方をやっているんです
それで 私たちはいろんなことを考えたり
妄想したり 悩んだりするのも
心にすごい不安定とイライラ状態がある
落ち着かないんです これは物質の安定を目指す変化とは違います
まあ物質はもう安定を目指して変化しているんですけど
それはそのまま放っておけばいいです
雨が降るは洪水になるは
すぐまあそのまま放っておけばいいんです
どうする必要はないんです
でも 心の不安定はなんとかしなくちゃあかんですね
心は不死を目指して変化します
違うところは 心がなんか変で不死
死にたくないという気持ちを持ってるんです
心は死ぬのは嫌だと初めから思っているんです
これ手足なんか死ぬのは嫌だと思ってないんです
体どこも死にたくないと思ってないんです
心臓も肺も腎臓も肝臓も
死にたくないと思ってないんです
ただの機械だからね 活動して毎日毎日衰えていくだけで
でも我々は死にたくないと思ってるでしょ
あれ 心が死にたくないんですね
だから心臓が弱くなったら心配して治療する
肺が弱くなったら心配して治療する
頑張ってます だから心が変化するのは
不死という安定を目指して変化しているのです
しかし 心も因縁により起こるので
安定 不死は成り立たないんです
しかし 心は心の勉強しないんです
まずできないんです これはお釈迦様だけが行ったことなんです
心って何なのかと よく科学的に見ると
因縁によって生じる現象にしか何もないんです
ありとあらゆるものを因縁によって現れる一時的な一時的な現象なんです
花にしたっても 物質はいろいろ変わって花っていうことになる
光っていうものも 物質はいろいろ変化して光っていうことになる
そんな一時的なんです
原因がなくなったら消える
だから今の光は電気に生まれているんだから
電気がなくなった瞬間で光は消える
心もないです 原因で現れる現象なんです
永遠に変わらない何かじゃないんです
これは勘違いです 心は変わります
いつでも変わっている
変わってもいいでしょう
地球の自転公転みたいに別に面倒問題じゃないでしょ
でも心は不死を期待しているんだから
ですから 仏教的にはこの心が目指す目的は成り立たない
不死っていうのは 心が無駄なことを期待しているんです
ということは 心はすーっと失敗するんです
わかりますか？ポイントは
行動しても結果は期待したものではありません
だったら失敗です 例えば
私はこの水をあげて飲もうとする
こぼれたら失敗です なぜならそれは期待したしなかった結果です
正しく飲めたら成功です
こうやればそれ成功じゃない
こちらはもうこぼれた
ということは 心がいつでも失敗する
心は何やっても失敗する
成功した試しはありません
よく覚えてください これは仏教の中で一番難しいポイントです
一般的な仏教じゃないんです
かなり超エリートしかし理解しないものなんです
心は常に失敗 失敗 失敗
失敗 失敗で動いています
失敗すると気持ちは気持ち悪い
落ち込む 悩む 苦しむ 嘆く
いろいろでしょ 悩み 苦しみ
憂いなどなど ない人がいる
ね これさらに大げさにしたら
大げさではなくて そういう風にしなくちゃあかんのです
皆様方はこちらにある花を見てください
心ですね 目で見て まあ花ですと
心で決める あれ 正解？正解ではないです
だって心は常に失敗するんだから
では何なのかと聞いてもわからないでしょ
この花を見て認識する時でも
不死を期待して見ているんです
だからありのままに見えない
音を聞いても同じことです
私の話を聞いたっても
気持ち良くなる人もたまにいるし
気持ち悪くなった人もたまにいるし
あんなのわからないと腹が立つ人もいるし
いるよ なんで？不死というメインオブジェクティブ目的があって
それに合わせて...見たりすると聞いたりする
感じたりする 何か食べたら
私は最近ある子供にその質問を出したんです
私は皆様にも子供に出す質問出した方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったりもしますけど
その子供に聞いたのは
あんた 美味しいという言葉の意味わかってますか？わかります
まずいという言葉わかります
では聞きますけど なんで味に美味しいと不味いと言うんですかね
はい 答えてみてくださいと
それで子供はもう一生懸命考える羽目になるんです
だってよく当たり前のことを聞いているんだから
では これ仏教的に この仏教の真髄のところから質問すると
考えなくちゃいけない
なんで味に美味しい不味いと言うんですか？と
それからの対話 忘れちゃったんですけどもね
子供が答えなかったら
私が答え正解を教えてあげようと思っていたのに
まあちょっと覚えてないです
皆様知ってますかね？なんで味に美味しい不味いとラベル貼るんですか？子供に聞いた質問だからね
答えられるはずないです
子供はそれなりに何か正解に近い答えは出しましたけど
一番簡単に考えていけば
美味しいということは自分では味わいたい味ですね
まずいとラベルを貼るのは
味わいたくない...味です
でしょ なんで味わいたい味があるんですか？というと
これ味わったら気分が良くて
気持ちよくなっちゃって生きられるんです
まずいとラベルを貼ったものは
食べる羽目になっちゃうと
気持ちが悪くなっちゃって
嫌な気分になっちゃって
生きることに邪魔になるんです
ですから 美味しいか不味いかラベルを貼るのは誰ですかね
心の中にある死にたくないという不死の目的から判断しているんです
成り立たない目的から
ありえない目的から  ですから
私たちは美味しい 美味しいということには何の根拠もないんです
なぜならば 私は美味しい
美味しいと言ったっても
他の人はいや これは美味しくないと言うんだから
私はまずいと言うのに
他の人はこれは美味しいですよと言うんだから
日本人が寿司がすごい美味しいと思っているんだけど
インド文化系の人々は超まずいと思っているんだから
超気持ち悪い だから根拠がないんですよ
客観的な根拠がないんです
そこで美味しいまずい判断するのは
存在欲から 心にある生きていきたい
死にたくないという この不死を期待する
あの要望というかね そこからその問題が起こるのです
ということは 何か触ってこれは気持ちいいと言ったっても
これは気持ち悪いと言ったっても
触って結局は自分の存在を応援するものは気持ちいい感触
応援しないものは気持ち悪い感触になるのです
我々が気持ち悪いと思うところで
ものすごい気持ちよく生活する生物もいるんですね
例えば 前の例え出したカエルさんが住んでいるところは
私たちは気持ち悪いところですよ
草の中で湿気があるところで
泥があって ヌメり気があって
それは気持ち悪い でもカエルさんにとっては超気持ちいい
カエルさんを取ってきて
あのね カエルさん この布団の方が気持ちいいよ
置いておいても カエルさんが気持ち悪い
逃げます だから何か触って気持ちいい
気持ち悪いと言ったっても
そんなのは正解ではないんです
ですから 元に戻りましょう
心は常に失敗する 心は認識するんだけど
これ正しい認識じゃないんです
如実の認識じゃないんです
ありのままの認識じゃないんです
例えば 我々は暗闇でロープを踏んじゃって
ヘビだと言ってものすごいびっくりしちゃって
怖くなって冷や汗が出て
ギャーッと泣いて心臓ドキドキして
それで光を当ててみたら
ただのロープです だから失敗でしょ
あの認識は いつだってそういうことです
いつだって私たちの認識は
暗闇でロープを踏んだような感じなんです
それから失敗に怯える
心の失敗は死を意味します
失敗に対して冷静にいられません
そこで心は失敗しているのに
一部のことは失敗だとわかるのです
すべてわかっていないのです
私はまあたまたま失敗しましたと言って
すごい調子に乗っているんです
そんな失敗するわけないで
まあたまたまかもしれませんよと
えらい調子 それで失敗したと気づいたら
あ まずいことをやったと怯えるんです
なんで失敗したら気持ち悪い怯えるかというと
失敗とは不死なんです
心にとっては失敗は死です
誰も失敗者で冷静にいられません
動物の場合 一回の判断ミスで命を失うことがあることですね
動物の場合 わかりやすい
バッタとカエルさんの場合は
バッタが飛ぶことに失敗したら命も終わる
だから動物たちは我々より怯えているんです
恐ろしく怯えているんです
動物の世界で一回の失敗ですべて終わる
人間はそうではないが
失敗を極端に恐れます
人間はまあそんなに失敗しても死ぬわけじゃないんだけど
でもブッダに及びます
ネクタイの柄が合わなかったというところから
ありとあらゆるすべての失敗は存在欲から発生します
ネクタイを締めたんだけど
ちょっと柄が合わない
失敗でしょ？悩むでしょ
そんなこと それで死ぬわけないでしょうにね
でも 大変に悩みますよ
結婚式に行って さっさとネクタイを持って無心で結んでみたんだけど
もう結婚式場でちょっと見たら
これ葬式に 使うネクタイでした
どうですかね その時の気持ちは
なんか火の上で歩いているような感じでしょう
別にそれで死ぬわけじゃないし
だからそういうどうでもいい失敗さえも
私たちにとってはすごい精神的なショックを与えるんです
存在を脅かすんです 自分の
それで私は最後のポイントで言いたいのは
すべての失敗は存在欲から現れるんです
心が生きていきたいという気持ちで変化しているんです
そうではない場合は失敗だと解説します
失敗は当然のことなんです
個が生きるために判断して行動します
全体的に状況を調べて客観的な立場で思考することも判断することもできません
個人にはその子の心があるんです
その心が自分が福祉を目指して生きているんです
だから 自分が生きていることの目的で
物事を見たり 聞いたり
判断したりするんですけど
真理は何なのかと見る気持ちは毛頭ない
現実は何なのか 事実は何なのかとは毛頭ない
自分が生きられるかないかだけなんですね
自我 自分という気持ちがある限り
生命の判断は正しくないんです
ですから 自分が生きていきたいという気持ちで物事を見ている間は
すべての判断 認識は間違っています
失敗です どのように判断して行動を起こしても
生命は世界に迷惑をかけつつ生きていて
必ず死にます だから大失敗です
生きている上でも 我々はあまり
もう他人に自然に迷惑
迷惑 迷惑をかけている
自己自我でしょ 自分が生きていきたい
では成功する？しない
大失敗通り死ぬんです
なんで人間が死は自然でしょ
でも認めないでしょ お母さん
お母さんが死にましたと言わないでしょ
認めません 亡くなりました
同じことですけど 他界しました
その言葉のごまかしも
やっぱり死は認めたくない
これは間違い 大失敗という気持ちから生まれるんです
ある有名なお医者さんが私に言った言葉なんですけど
我々医者っていうのはすごい非科学的
非現実的だと 私たちは死は敵だと思っているんだと
だからどうやってもこの患者さんは死なせは死なせません
必死 でもこれっておかしいと
科学的に見ると 人は死ぬんだと
なのに私たちはそれを認めない
何としてでも生かそうとする
何なのか これは 今日死ぬはずの人が明日死ぬことになる
だから何ですか それは
そういうことで その先生は
この自分で病院を作ったんで
この ホスピスみたいにもう治らない末期の患者さんのために
そちらで仕事を取っていて
だからその場合はもう死ぬのは当たり前ということで
患者さんもそれを知って
医者もそれを知っていて
手当てをする インチキ嘘はない
大丈夫 大丈夫 治してあげますからとかね
今の医療はものすごい発展していますから
大丈夫 そんな嘘はない
うん はい それは失敗は現実として見る
失敗に対するブッダの立場
これからちょっと仏教の話に入ります
出家の失敗 誰だって失敗しますよ
出家したんだからといって成功するわけじゃないんです
私が言うのは 呼吸するように当たり前なんです
失敗は だから精密に仏教的に言えば
何やっても失敗だよってなんです
あんた成功すると思うなよ
何一つも成功しません
それで複数の戒律を守らなくてはいけない出家は結構失敗しています
戒律の数は億飛んでるんです
覚えられる？覚えられません
だから失敗します 実践するしても
修行を撤回することも失敗します
お釈迦様の瞑想を実践しようと思ったら
失敗 失敗 失敗 ブッダの教えを勉強して理解しようと思ったら失敗だらけ
何一つも覚えられないです
しかし お釈迦様の優れたところは
人は失敗するんだと知っているんです
知っていて 失敗するなよと脅すのです
脅してもお釈迦様の教えは
もう直接読むとすごい怖いんですよ
ものすごく脅してるんです
しかし これはね あんた失敗するんだよ
実践と心理の誤解は先輩との対話によって直します
実践すると失敗すると先輩に聞いてみて直してもらう
心理に対して誤解があったら対話して直してもらう
だから我々はずっと先輩に尊敬していつでも教えてもらう
いつでも出家に法について対話しなさと言っているんです
わかったつもりでいるなよ
例えば出家なら誰だって子供の時から覚えているアッパーマードアとかだ
あのえっと 不放逸は不死なりという言葉がありますね
放逸は死を意味するとか
ダンマパダでもすごく有名な偈なんですね
あまり仏教を知らなくても
それでも対話はした方がいいんです
他のお坊さん見たら この不放逸は不死なりってどんな意味ですかね？どう理解しているんですかねと
それでその後 私はこのように理解している
それで自分も私はこのように理解していると対話して
より理解を深めていくんです
ずっとやらなくちゃいけないです
戒律についての失敗は
他の出家の前で報告して素直に認めます
戒律を失敗する 食べることで失敗する
歩くことに失敗する 衣をまとうことで何か失敗すると
戒律を破ったことになるんですね
破ったら他のお坊さんにそれを報告するんです
私はいろいろ戒律の中で失敗しましたと
報告したら その受けたお坊さんははい
認めます これを失敗として認めます
あんたはこれから気をつけますか？はい
これから気をつけます
はい それでよい はい これも毎日のようにやらなくちゃいけないんです
毎日できない場合は この週に一回
二回でもやってくださいと
報告を受ける出家はそれを認めて
これから気をつけてくださいと言わなくてはならない
それが決まりです お釈迦様の
あんた失敗したのかい？勝手にしなさい
知らないそんなのはと言ったら
これも戒律違反なんです
謝りました ああ そうですか
では気をつけてください
これから それがいい だから皆様の社会みたいに
なんでそんなことをするのかとかね
それで困りますよと それは禁止
仏教では これ 愚か者の社会ではあるんです
仏教の社会ではないんです
仏教の中では人は失敗する
それは当たり前  です しかし
そのまま失敗しましたと言わなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあこれから気をつけて頑張ってねと言うのは大丈夫です
すごい優しい世界なんです
愚か者は失敗を認めない
デーネディケーバーラヨーチャアッチャアッチャとパッサティヨーチャアッチャデーセンタッセヤターダンマナッパリガンナーということなんですね
意味は愚か者は二種類です
一 失敗を失敗として見えないもの
失敗しているのに これは失敗じゃないと勘違いしている
それは愚か者なんです
失敗を報告しても認めないもの
だから愚か者 愚か者っていうのは
仏道には失格という意味なんです
だから仏教徒は失敗して
あ これは失敗だと素直に認めなくてはいけない
それは先輩に報告していたら
先輩もああ それは失敗でしょう
これから気をつけてくださいと言わなくちゃいけないんです
あるいは報告する先輩がこんな程度は失敗やと言わないよとかね
いいじゃない これで 今の社会ではこんな精密に規則を守りませんだからとか
偉そうなことを言ったらとんでもない愚か者なんです
失敗は認めなくちゃいけないんです
だから愚か者とお釈迦様は言ってるんです
この二つ 智者は失敗を正しく認識します
失敗したら これは失敗だと知ります
他人の失敗もあるままに認めます
それは仏道で その人は仏道で成功します
成功するためにはそれは必要な条件なんです
人は失敗するんだぞということ
だから俗世間とは違います
失敗したら あるエピソードからこの文章を取ったんです
読むのはやめましょうね
長
すぎだから アッチャーノーバンティーアッチャガマーヤターダレヤターモンデヤターアプセレーデーマヤンエワンソアッカーテダンマウィレーパブリックイタサマーナ
アンニマンニャンシュテーナアッチャアワディンマエイビッコウコウバフタランバシセティコウサンダルタランバシスティコウチタタランバシセティティヘーサンノー
バンティーバガワアッチャアッチャイトパティバンナートアーティンサンムラーヤーティ
これはもうマハーカッサパ尊者にお釈迦様があんたの弟子たちに説法しなさいと頼んだんです
だからマハーカッサパ尊者はできません
この比丘たちは出来が悪い
お釈迦様に断るんです
お釈迦様に命令されているにも関わらず
マハーカッサパ尊者っていうのはすごい大事な尊者で
サーリプッタモクレン尊者が一番トップの二人で
それより3番目もいたんですね
その方は隠れていたんです
あんまりお釈迦様にも顔を合わせないんです
でお釈迦様がかなり物事を知っているんだから
お釈迦様は涅槃に入る
サーリプッタモクレン尊者がお釈迦様より先に亡くなる
そうすると この3番目に補完していたマハーカッサパ尊者が全責任を持って仏教を人類のために残す作業をするんです
だから本当にブッダの代わりを代表役をやる方なんです
だから今現在我々が学んでいる仏教がマハーカッサパ尊者が我々に教えた教えなんです
だからかなり立場がすごいんです
だからたまにお釈迦様にたまに稀に会うんだけど
会ったつもりで説法しなさいと
できませんと 出来が悪いんだと
この人々は で どういうエピソードかというと
このある若いお坊さん二人がお互い喧嘩しているんですね
どういう悪い喧嘩ではなくて
じゃあ二人で  誰が誰にできますかね
たくさん説法すること
いわゆるたくさん仏教を覚えておいて説法すると結構できる
誰に？誰にたくさんできますかと
誰に見事に理解できるように説法できるのかと
誰に長く説法できるのかと
この二人が競争しているんです
そのようで出来が悪いと
マハーカッサ尊者が説法することは断った
いえ 説法しません あなた方みたいな生徒
それでお釈迦様に言ったところ
お釈迦様は本当ですか？とこの二人を呼んで聞いたんです
聞いたら二人は自分の間違いを認めたんです
本当に我々はこんなに素晴らしい教えの中に出家して自慢したんだと
誰がたくさん仏教を知っているんでしょうか
とんでもない間違いをしました
な よく読まなかった それでこの謝るんですね
この謝る文章 尚且つ 私たちは本当におらたもので失敗しました
見事に完全に解かれている教えの中に出家して
誰に見事に説法できるのか
誰に長く説法できるのかと競争しました
尚且つ 私たちのこの間違いを
私たちのしつけのために過ちとして認めてください
お釈迦様の前に謝ります
あなた方は失敗を失敗として認めて適切な対応するならば
失敗を許します もし誰かが失敗しても
それを認めて適切な対応するならば
そのことはこの教えにおいて成長というのです
この二行目ですね 今日の講演のポイント
ブッディーヘイサービッカリーありあせいない
仏教においては これ成長というんでしょう
よっあっちゃーんあっちゃいとディスは失敗は失敗であると確認して
ヤターダンマンパリカトーティ
それなりの対応をする
アイティンサングリンアッパジェ
これからもっと気をつけますということになる
そうすると人は徐々に成長して解脱にまで成功していくのです
ですから 仏教の場合は解脱に達しなければ
我々は一つ 私は失敗するんだよと認めなくちゃいけないんです
私は失敗するんだよ 失敗に怯えるんじゃないんです
はい 次 成長の順番を考えてみましょう
人は失敗する 間違いを犯す
それを勇気を持って認める
適切な処置をする  二度と同じ失敗をしないように学ぶ
それから次の失敗に変わる
不完全な人が完成性を目指して成長します
たって簡単でしょ 失敗だとしたものは認めて
それを直す また失敗があったらそれも直す
また失敗を見つけたらそれも直す
それで最終的には悟り達します
で なんで失敗するのかっていうことね
いくつかの理由はね 前説明しましたけど
失敗を引き起こす人の精神状態
自我と煩悩の問題 だいたいそれなんですね
自我の錯覚がある人は
物事を主観的に自分の好都合で情報を捏造して認識します
だから私たちには自我の錯覚があるし
ですから主観で物事を見ているんですね
だから情報は入りますけど
情報を捏造するんで 自分の好都合で
だから失敗するのは当たり前
これは自然に起こる現象です
誰でもやっているんです
ですから すべての判断には客観性はありません
私に正しいものは他人に正しくないんです
自我の錯覚があるから
失敗を認めない 隠そう
いいわけをしようと努力をする
人間やっていることは
失敗したら隠そうとするんです
あるいはいいわけをするんです
なんか失敗したことは変だと思っているんです
誰だって失敗しかしないんだから
そんな問題ないでしょう
失敗のないものと 失敗のない人は成長しません
失敗したんだって言って落ち込んだら
もう見込みがない人です
自我が強すぎです 私に限って失敗するはずはないと思っているんです
とんでもないやつです
さらに恐ろしい失敗をしてしまいます
そういう人々は さらに恐ろしい失敗をしてしまうのです
自分が人間として退化します
その人は退化します 失敗に悩む人は退化します
人間は様々 失敗が少ない人
多い人 失敗しない人などなどがいます
失敗しかしない人 失敗を隠す人
隠さない人 一部隠す人
失敗は正しいと勘違いしている人
失敗は当たり前だと思って無責任に行動する人
大胆な失敗する人 失敗を恐れて何もしない人とか
いろいろいるんですよ
これは各人の煩悩の働きによって起こる現象です
こうやってたくさんの人がいるのは
それぞれの人の煩悩の働き方なんです
では 仏弟子の道 失敗から学ぶ
失敗は師匠です 誰だって正しい
真理を知らない人は皆
自分が正しいと思っています
生命のすべての行為は正しいという前提で起こるものです
我々がやっていることは全部正しい
正しい 正しいと思ってやっているんです
ですから 失敗しても 無限に輪廻転生しても
生命には成長がないんです
正しいと思っているんだから直さないでしょ
だから これは何ですか？と皆様に聞いたら花ですと言うでしょ
正解ですね 正解だと思っているんです
だから これは何なのかと改めて見ようとはしないんです
それで我々は死んで また生まれて
また死んで また生まれて
無限に輪廻転生する でもいつでも私は正しいという立場ですね
だから成長はないんです
仏弟子の違うところを間違いに気づく
ブッダのところで真理を学ぶと
人間は間違いだらけの生き方をしているのだと発見する
仏教を学んできたら あれ？私たちは間違いだらけではないかとわかるんです
最初に受ける五戒も 自分が間違った生き方していたことを認める行為です
例えばブッダの教えを聞いて
じゃあ私も真面目な人間になろうと思った時点で
今までの生き方は間違ったと認めたことでしょう
では 最初のステップとして五戒を守りましょうということは
今まで間違った生き方をしたんだという確認なんです
私は殺生しませんということは
今まで殺生したんだということですよ
それは間違いです 間違い直します
これから私は与えられていないものは取りません
取りませんと 今までは与えて与えてあろうがなかろうが関係なく
美味しいものを取っちゃっていた
取ったんです これは間違いです
間違い生き方を直しているんです
ですから 五戒を受けるとは失敗を認めることです
三宝に帰依する人は 仏教を勉強すると
やっぱり三宝に帰依しましょうという希望になるんです
そうなったら 今までやってきた迷信
信仰 神頼みの生き方は
欲にまみれた感情的な生き方であったと発見しているからなんです
すべて神に任せちゃって
神様は助けてちょうだいと
それは欲にまみれた生き方なんです
気持ち悪い生き方なんです
病気になるのは当たり前でしょう
神様はこの病気を治してちょうだいと
えらい調子ですね だからそんなのはかっこ悪いんだと
私はありのままに生きてみる
だから三宝に帰依すると
だからブッダンサラナンガッチャミと言うとことさえも
自分の失敗に気づくことなんです
今まで間違った人の教え
煩悩のにやられている人々の教えをやっていた
今日からは悟った人の教えに従って生きてまーすと
ブッダンサラナンガッチャミ
それも自分の間違いに気づくことです
また順番書きます 初めはすべての失敗に気づきません
人っていうのは 仏教の人はね
すべての間違いに失敗に気づきませんよ
だって見ただけでも間違いだから
それはわからないでしょう
ご飯食べるとおいしいなと思うでしょう
でもそれ間違いだとわかってないでしょ
だからすべてに気づきませんよ
自分の理解能力に合ったことのみ失敗して認める
普通に生きていて ついカッとなって喧嘩した
あ 失敗しました これからはカッとなって喧嘩することをやめると
そこで気をつける そうやって気づいた失敗で十分です
例人を殺すのは悪いが
魚を殺すのは仕方がないと思っている人がいるでしょ
人を殺すのは悪いとわかっている
だからその人はその失敗は閉まっている
死骸 魚を殺す 殺されるようになったら
相手を殺しても自己防衛なので罪になりませんと思っている人もいるでしょ
私はもう誰も殺しませんだけど
でも自分を殺す人だと
自分を守るために殺す
それは仕方がないと だからその人も自分の理解程度で殺してはならないと思っているんです
でも まだまだ正しくないんです
智慧がある人は殺されても生命を殺すのは間違いだと知るんです
そこでどんどん智慧が現れてくると
なるほど 殺生してはいけませんということは
たとえ私は殺されても
私が相手を殺してはならない
とわかったら もう一つ項目完成です
1 日でそれはできませんよ
だから私の仲間の中でもそういう人々が結構いるんです
酒は飲まないんだけど
まあ晩酌ぐらいは ちゃんと 1杯ぐらいはということで
それも一つ自分を戒めているんですよ
間違いじゃないんです
まあ殺生をやめたんだけど
蚊だけはちょっとごめんと蚊を殺すんだけど
他の生物は殺せません
では まあその人は自分にできる範囲で
自分が理解できる範囲で頑張っているんです
そういう風に もうまあ自分にできる範囲で頑張っている人々も
もう仲間 私の知っている人々の間でも
やっぱり結構じわじわと成長するんです
じわじわとうまくいくんです
それでいいではなくて
それが道です  1 日にして完全な人間になれます
1 日で仙人にはなりません
自分が発見する失敗を認める
なぜ失敗したのかとその理由を発見する
二度と同じ失敗をしないように
どうすれば良いのかと調べたり
他人に教えてもらったりする
ただそれだけ 素直にその通りに生きてみる
例えば いろんな酒がね
もう好きな人が日本酒やらウイスキーやら
もう蒸留酒いっぱい好きな人が
仏教系だとここで飲酒会もありますから
困ったな では私は酒やめてビールぐらいにしました
その人は本人にできる範囲で頑張ってるんじゃない
蒸留酒は飲まない 強すぎだから
まあビールぐらいはいいんじゃないかと
それからもっと智慧が現れてくると
まだ戒律守ってないでしょ
私は じゃあビールの量も減らしましょうと
最終的にはあのビール 1杯もやめてしまう
それで飲酒会関係がないんです
だから失敗したくないという気持ちが必要なんですね
これを覚えておきましょう
失敗したら恥ずかしくなって落ち込むんじゃないんで
そんなもんもう人間じゃない
退化する人なんだ これは呼吸することと同じで
毎日失敗する人生なんです
気づいた失敗をこのステップで
なんでここを失敗するんですか？例えば蒸留酒をやめた人が
でも私はビール飲んでるでしょうにと
これはお酒でしょうにと
でもなんで私はこれを飲んでるんですか？やっぱり私は酒飲むの好きみたい
愛着がある あるいはいろいろ悩みを誤魔化そうとしてみろ
あるいは酒に依存している
なんかこれちょっとまずい
じゃあ頑張ってこれもやめてみたら
見たらどうでしょうかとかね
そうすると自分でできない場合はどうしましょうかといったら
まあ今は最近ね アルコール入ってないビールはありますからとかね
ビールの味もあって 香りもあって
色もないビールで それにしたらどうですかと
そうするといきなり愛着を捨てられませんだからビールもどきを飲んでみて
どんどんなんで体に悪い
あるいは体に悪いものだからね
もう飲まなくちゃあかんかっていうと
やめちゃいますと お茶にします
お茶にしますということはできます
そうやって徐々に頑張ればいいんです
素直にその通りにしてみて
しかし 別な失敗をする
例えば一つの失敗はもう OK なんですけど
次に次の失敗が現れる
酒はやめているんだけど
嘘をつく まあまあダメですね
それにも同じで 治って治っていく
大胆に嘘をついて誤魔化す
人を騙すことはやめる
でも人を笑わせるためには嘘
嘘をつくとかね どんどん笑わせるためであっても
嘘は悪いなとか分かってくるんですね
時々わかってはいるがやめられないという状態もある
これもありますね これ悪い
まずいと知ってるんだけど
やめられない その場合も
その時いきなりやめようではなくて
やめられないんだからね
自分は感情に依存していること
理解は不十分であることを発見できます
やめられない場合 なんでやめられないのかといえば
なんか依存している 依存とは感情ですね
あるいは本当に分かっていない
分かってはいるがと言ってもね
本当に分かっている だからより分かるようにする
例えばタバコはやめたいんだけど
悪いと分かっているのにやめられない
ということは 本当にタバコは悪いと分かってないんです
だったらタバコの成分は何なのか
体にどんな影響を与えるのかと
とことん文章をとって読んで読んでみていけば
がんになったケースとか治療の写真とかね
いっぱい見て もう理解は十分
そうするとタバコの煙がものすごい猛毒のように感じる
そこでもうあれもありますから
何といいますか ニコチン依存症のね
だからどんどん頑張っていると
ニコチン依存することも
なくなって 綺麗に煙草から解放されますね
そういう風にやめられない場合も
そういう順番でやらなくちゃあかんですね
直すべき失敗はないと発見するまで進みますよ
こういうことで 大きな失敗からどんどん大きな失敗しない人は
戒律はちゃんと守っている
でも小さな失敗する 食べ過ぎになったり
いろいろそういうとこも直っていきますよ
寝過ぎになったり いろいろ
そういう細かい失敗にそれから行く
最後にこれだと綺麗な花だ
美しいなと それも間違いです
そこでヴィパッサナー実践なんかやっていると
そうでもないねとかね
これは無常で 認識がね
生まれては消える 生まれては消える
生まれては消える 綺麗な花だっていうことは頭の錯覚やとかわかるんですね
そうするとそこでも落ち着く
そこで最終的にはあれ
直るところはないということは仕事終わったんですね
失敗から学ぶことは終わったんです
その人は無学というんです
ということは阿羅漢になっているんです
そういうことで どうしても最終的にはヴィパッサナー実践というものになるんですね
初めから終わりまで失敗の連続でヴィパッサナー実践は
成功すると思ったら勘違いです
でお釈迦様のプログラムだから
お釈迦様は失敗から学ぶプログラムを作っているんです
なぜならば心が失敗しか何もしないんです
これは精密な科学世界です
あの世の中での瞑想とは違うんです
いい気分にしてあげる
光を見た 魂を体験しました
神様を体験しましたとか
そんな精神的な病気です
あれは そうじゃないんです
すごい精密な科学で失敗を発見して直す
発見して直す 発見して直す
ヴィパッサナー実践はそれなんです
だからヴィパッサナー実践始めた人は
初めからもう失敗する
それで直そうとする 直ったらまた別なことを失敗する
それを直す また別なことを失敗するっていう連続です
失敗という方に過ち 罪というのがあります
人間の世界では過ち 罪を犯した
人殺した 強盗しました
それは失敗です ヴィパッサナー実践の実践する場合は
失敗はあるが 罪ではありません
ヴィパッサナー実践に入り入ったら罪は犯しません
でも失敗はする 例えば左足上げますと言っているのに
上げてるのは右足ですね
失敗でしょ でも罪を犯したわけじゃないんです
サマタ瞑想と違って ヴィパッサナー実践する人はなかなか成長している
成功しているという気持ちは起こりません
だから安心してください
ヴィパッサナー実践 ああ
じゃあうまくいったということはないんです
やっぱりガタガタですね
今日は いつでもうまくいかなかったっていう気分です
これはブッダの瞑想のプログラムはそうなっているんです
ヴィパッサナーで確認すると
ラベリングがあるとどうしても失敗ばっかり見えてくるんです
例えば妄想してはいけないと言ってるでしょ
妄想妄想と言ってるのに
また妄想 失敗でしょ また妄想妄想で言ったのに
また妄想 そこで何かしら何かどこかで自分が学んで成長していくのです
しかし 実践者は失敗を直さないことはならないです
だからって調子に乗ってはあかん
ああ どうせ失敗するんだから
まあいいや それはダメです
正しくやろうとしないと
妄想してはいけませんと言ったら
妄想しないように頑張らないと
それは必要です 頑張っても失敗するんだよと知っています
直ったら別な失敗が起こるんです
このように失敗しないで正しく実践しようと励む過程で
徐々に智慧が現れてくるのです
心が成長して煩悩が弱くなっていきます
微細な失敗も直そうとするところで瞑想は成功して
心が解脱に達します 最終的に微細な失敗も直そうとするのです
それでパッと心が解脱に達してしまいます
自己観察するというものがあります
皆 自分の過ち 他人の過ちなら直ちに発見します
自分の過ちは自分が過ち
自分の過ちは過ちとして認めません
これは普通の人間のやり方
他人が自分の失敗を示すことさえも嫌がります
あのね これ間違いだよと言われて気持ち悪い
例えば自分がゴミをポイと捨てる
後ろに誰か あのね ゴミをそんなことしないでくださいと言われたら気持ち悪いでしょう
すごい気持ち悪い 仏教は他人のことを置いておいて
自己観察を推奨します
自分のこと見なさい 間違いだらけの汚れた嫌な自分に遭遇します
自己観察すると 間違いだらけの嫌な自分に会います
会いなさいなんです 逃げるんじゃなくて
厳格に言ってはいけません
私は正しいという 私は神の子であるとかね
なんだこれ 病気です ただのゴミの塊だと
はっきりと直面してほしい
自分に勇気が必要です
だから仏教だけ自己観察というものを教えるのです
サマタ瞑想の場合は 呼吸を見るは光を見て瞑想する
自己観察じゃないんです
だからいい気持ちになるかもしれませんだけど
智慧は現れません しかし
失敗は師匠であると知っています
それで嫌な自分に会っても大丈夫です
師匠です 例えば食べ物には目がなくて
いつでも食い過ぎ 自己観察すると気持ち悪い自分が食べ物を見たら食って
無駄でしょうから  はい
そこで気持ち悪くならない
これが師匠です 鏡で自分を見えたんです
お釈迦様は鏡という例えを使っているんです
鏡を自分の息子に教えたんです
鏡のたとえ自己観察 若者は鏡を見て自分のいけないところを直すんだよと
だから お化粧する若者が鏡を見て
私って美しいなあと思ったら
何も直さないでしょ そうすると
鼻はちょっとだ 唇はちょっと
これはちょっと影が見えてくると
いろいろ色を塗ったり
トーンを入れたりして
だから間違いを直してるんですね
だから間違いを見えなかったら直せないでしょう
だから自己観察すると間違いを見る
失敗を見る それが師匠です
それを直せばいいんです
すぐカッとなる自分を見える
それで自分を直せます
実践をやめるのではなく
失敗を直すことに励みます
例えば自己観察すると
ああ 怒りやら欲やら悩みやら恨みやら
もう嫌なこっちゃ こんなことを考えちゃうと
私は病気になるかもしれない
そう やめるというのはもう
失敗に失敗したんです
失敗を嫌がったんです
その人は退化するんです
ではなくて ああ そうか
ではこれを直そう ああ
私はこういうものか それを直そう
私は言葉使い悪いね じゃあ直す
私は結構怠け者ですね
じゃあ直すという風に直せばいいんです
いわゆる実践はやめません
毎日失敗しているのに
人格的向上して 的に向上して
失敗が少ない 失敗の少ない人間として成長しているのです
まあ自分には失敗だらけなんです
いくらなんでも でも客観的に見るともう成長している
ヴィパッサナー実践をやっている人々も 1
年ぐらいやってみると
前の人間とはものすごい違う人間に変わっているんです
しかし 瞑想をやってみたら
まだ間違いだらけ うまくいっていない
でもちゃんと成長しているんです
だから自分が成長しているかどうか調べなくてもいいんだけど
調べる方法はあるんですよ
最初に発見した間違いと今発見する間違いは違うんですね
最初はちょっと足が痛くなっただけで瞑想は壊れる
今はそれはないとかね
最初は妄想が出たらずっと妄想して 10 分やっと気づく
今はそうじゃない 妄想が始まるともうわかっている
最初は座ったらもう寝ている
30 分瞑想したら 29 分寝て 1
分だけ瞑想 今は 30 分座ったら
28 分の瞑想をしていて
2 分は寝ていると そういう感じで失敗は変わっているんです
気づく失敗変わったということは成長したということなんです
無明を破る 貪瞋痴をなくす
煩悩を滅しなどの用語は結局失敗から学ぶという意味です
皆様方 仏教用語に引っかかっちゃうと悟れないんですよ
だってあの この経典と仏典というテキスト 2種類あるんですね
で 経典はもうブッダの言葉だから
そんな問題ないんだけど
全然問題ないんだけど
経典だけ読んで修行することはできるんだけど
経典にわからないことがあるんだね
そうすると 仏典で注釈書を読んで勉強するでしょ
それで悟れなくなっちゃうんですよ
なぜかというと 専門用語だらけで
学術的に精密に説明しているからね
悟りとは貪瞋痴を根絶することである
ああ そうか では私は貪瞋痴を根絶してうまくできるわけないでしょうに
悟るとは煩悩の滅尽であると
じゃあ私は煩悩滅尽するができる？煩悩も何かもわかってないんだから
だから実際そうじゃなくて
失敗から学ぶなんです
だから自己観察するんです
そうすると失敗だらけの
間違いだらけの もう腐っている自分を見つかるんです
そこは一つ一つ一つずつ直していくだけ
最終的に自分が煩悩を滅尽しているんです
日常生活の場合 側辺 話は終わりました
まあちょっと即席にちょっと当てはめてみます
失敗してはならない 言わなくても人は失敗したくないんです
でも 失敗したくないというふうに思った方がいいんですね
より強く それで結構です
しかし 失敗したら これは失敗です
謝りですと自分で素直に認める勇気はありますか？ここなんで問題は
失敗隠すんじゃなくて
失敗に悩むんじゃなくて
落ち込むんじゃなくて
あ 失敗だ 認められる それは立派な人間なんです
ないならば信頼できないだらしのない人間です
勇気を持って認めることはできないんだったら
もう諦めてください もう処分するべき人間です
勇気があるならば 立派な見込みのある人間です
だから皆様にそれぐらいできるでしょう
仏教は関係なく 世間で立派な人間になるために失敗しないと決めておく
失敗したら勇気を持って
これは失敗です 認めればいいんです
あの国会の議論とかを聞いてみると
政治家っていうのは失敗しても絶対認めませんね
だからどんな国でも政治家っていうのは最悪なんです
人格者じゃないんです
そこで野党側 与党側に謝りなさい
国民にあなたに謝る権利がある
義務があるでしょうと
謝りませんね 関係ないものについては謝ります
偉そうに もう関係ないものに謝って
関係があるもの 自分が起こした失敗に言い訳するのはもうだらしない
もう人格者ではない 信頼できない
例えば部下がやったことで
大変申し訳ございませんでした
蹴っ飛ばしてもいいんです
自分の過ちを隠している
政治家よく言うでしょ？首相がやったことをね
私はいちいち調べませんとかね
気をつけても失敗をする
失敗しないとはありえない現象です
やはり失敗します 自分の失敗を他人に言われるまで気づかない人間は愚かです
人に言わない限り 失敗したとわからないんだったら
もう愚か者ですよ 例えば子供の場合はそうでしょう
ずっと誰かがもう失敗直してあげなくちゃいけないでしょ
まあ子供のはしょうがないんですからね
まだまだ何も知らないんだから
だからずっと誰かが 大人が付きっきりでいないと死んじゃいますよ
子供失敗しちゃう 水遊びをする
いいんです 子供だから
でも誰か見張っていないと溺れてしまうの
大人もそんな調子でいいんですか
人に言われる前に自分の失敗に気づきましょう
ですから 人に言われる前に自分の失敗に気づかなくちゃいけないんですね
失敗は恥ずかしいものでも
隠すものでもありません
自然なものなんです 自分の未熟なところを教えてくれるアドバイス
顧問です 失敗っていうのは顧問です
別に隠す必要ないんです
私には立派な顧問がついてますよと言っても悪くないでしょ
だって人間だったら自慢するでしょ？すごい優秀なインテリの顧問がいるならば
私はこういうこういう人のアドバイスを受けて活動していますと自慢するんだから
ですから 自分の失敗に気づくことは自分の顧問なんです
だから教えてくれているんだからね
これですよと鏡を見せているんだから
これ直せばいいんですね
直すのは自分の責任です
失敗しないと学べないんです
これは法則ですが 意図的に失敗するのは罪です
失敗しなきゃ学べないと思ってね
あれやこれやと失敗しちゃうと
これ罪です 節操 節操悪いと節制しなきゃわからないと
痛いところった 冗談でしょ
だから失敗しないと学べないということは
おかしく使ってはいけません
意図的に失敗してはいけません
いつでも失敗しないようにと頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
無責任に行動してはならない
まあどうせ失敗するんだからいいや
いいやという無責任 とんでもない人間です
決して失敗だけはしませんという態度は欠かせません
運転するときは決して失敗しないという覚悟で運転しているでしょうに
人生もそのようにやってください
だからといって失敗しますよ
そのとき学ぶのです 意図的に作る失敗は禁止です
それは罪です 事故を起こさなかったら
事故の恐ろしさはわかりませんと言って事故を起こしていい？いいわけないでしょ
ちょっと気が飛んじゃって
ちょこっと事故を起こしちゃったら
それは失敗だよね それからものすごい気をつければいいんです
失敗とは正しいと思ってやったのに
結果は逆でしたと言える状態です
意図的にやる失敗は趣味です
失敗っていうのは自分が正しいとやったんです
でも結果は逆でした それが失敗
そこで直す 学ぶのです
子供の宿題と同じです
子供は宿題やってOK
全部できたと喜んでます
先生はペケペケペケ どうぞこのまま落ち込んで
あーこれ間違っちゃったとかね
だから直せばいいんです
決して宿題やってる子供は
足し算して答えは131だと知ってるくせに
724と書かないでしょ？子供は足し算で自分が正しいと思った数字を書くんです
先生はこれペケと言ったら
あ 失敗 それでまたやり直ったら失敗直ったことになる
人生ずっとそういうことなんです
私たちはやる時は正しいと思ってやっている
結果見たらうまくいっていないんです
ということは失敗ですね
それで正しいと思ったところは何なのか
なんでどこでなんで間違ったのかと学べばいいんです
試行錯誤にも気をつけるんです
試してみなくてはわからないのは当たり前です
しかし 自然に生命に危険を及ぼす試しはやめるべきです
試してみなきゃわからないです
特に科学世界ではすべて実験してデータを取って試すんですよ
だからといっていい加減にやるんじゃないんです
気をつけなければ ならない
原発はそういうものでしょう
危険だと知っていたのにも関わらず作りまくっちゃったんですね
大胆に借金して商売に手を出さない方が正しいんです
商売して儲けて借金返しますよというのは当たり前なんだ
だからといっていきなり大胆にではなくて
よく気をつけて 借金払える環境を作って
まあちょこちょこちょこちょこと商売した方がどんどん成長していくんです
いきなりバカでかいスーパーを始めるんじゃないんです
慈しみの気持ちがあるならば
試し 試行錯誤は構わないのです
そこで慈しみが割り込んできて
我々に慈しみがあればすごい安全です
慈しみというのは生命に対する態度でしょう
その人は試行錯誤は大丈夫です
やってみるのは大丈夫です
慈しみがあるんだから
大胆なことはしません
試してみるんだけど 生命のことは気をつける
生命の安全を考えておく
そのように試行錯誤をするんです
慈しみを持って 社会の問題は
人は失敗しても認めないこと
会社なんかで本当に困ることはそういうことなんです
失敗したらものすごく怒鳴って怒って
あれやこれやとか 汚いやり方
じゃない ですから 違法行為はなくならない
法律制度には大変な金も時間もかかります
だから失敗認めないんだから
もうみんな誤魔化すんですね
誤魔化しちゃうと もう法律作らなくちゃいけない
で 裁判制度がなければいけない
なんで裁判制度にそんなにお金がかかるのかって
時間がかかるのかというと
みんな失敗を認める 私は正しいと一生懸命誤魔化す
誤魔化す 誤魔化す だから社会ではものすごい資源がなくなるんです
不正をなくすために大事な資源が消えます
だから社会の不正をなくすためにものすごい大変ですよ
会社の中でもすごい金かかるんですよ
不正をなくす対策として
だって みんなもう何やるか意図的に悪いことをする
失敗を認める社会が現れるから
それが平和で豊かな社会の現れです
精神的な問題がない社会です
人は失敗したら あ これは失敗ですよ
気をつけてください これからやめてくださいと
はい わかりました ありがとうございます
これから絶対気をつけます
この失敗しませんという社会だったら
すごい気持ちいいです
だから人間は失敗する
失敗したら認めてください
これは失敗です なんであんたこんなことをするの？と言っちゃうと
その人は身を守るために誤魔化しをする
それで精神的にすごい苦しい世界がある
経済的にもガタガタな世界が
安定じゃないんです もし人は失敗を認める人間になったならば
社会は安定する 無常はなくなりませんだけど
精神的な悩みが消える
はい 俗と聖の差 失敗 過ち
罪 ごまかし 騙しなどで構成している社会は俗です
失敗から学ぶ過程は 俗世間から成長する
脱する道です 失敗しない人は聖者です
サットタイトルです これで講演は終わりとなります
はい そういうことで 失敗から見事に学んでいきましょう
失敗は我々の個人個人の立派な友です
はい できました  スマナサーラ先生ありがとうございます
えーと ちょっと終了時間を10分ほどオーバーしていますけど
ここで講演会を終了したいと思います
では 最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって集めたその功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らしますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーディーワジェントゥ サッブロークーウィニャッスクルマーテーバータンテーラーヨーサッビーデーワーユコーバーワープットサッブモッガランダカンサッ
ブデーヴァターサッブブッダヌバーゲナサッブダマーヌバーゲナサッブサンガヌバーゲヘナサダーサッティワントゥティアビワダナシーリッシャーニッチャンマンダー
パチャノーチャッターローダンマーヴァッキャニーパーユワンノー スカーンプラームー
サワディサーワディーサーワディー
ありがとうございます